how difficult is the process of knowing
understanding what is the righteous
action
of
knowing what it means to be a good man
or a good woman
well the truth has consequences so don't
seek out the truth unless you're willing
to abide by what you find so a lot of
people want to mold
their journey in accordance with a
predetermined Pursuit that they already
have and so when they approach religion
they approach it like another product
you know there was a uh an article that
was actually written by a rabbi I've
spoken about this in several sermons it
was called the Allure of narcissistic
spirituality the Allure of narcissistic
spirituality where he talks about
you know how religion becomes just
another product of your own
self adoration and worship to where you
only approach religion to the extent
that it gives you
more happiness in the worldly sense you
only approach of it what is therapeutic
so it becomes just as
secular
in its nature as any other practice of
meditation or whatever it may be or some
other product and it kind of mentions
you know how
uh he he took that from a person that is
praying in a temple and a guy walks into
the temple and bumps into him and then
he curses the guy out so he didn't see
his behavior towards that person as uh
part of his trajectory of worship he
just saw his being Godly as the worship
that he was engaged in the truth has
consequences the truth has circumstances
that are required of you actions that
are required of you that may be somewhat
inconvenient so you have to be willing
to engage in a sincere Pursuit Of Truth
and look for Truth for what it is
and not simply look for comfort and
convenience
and when you engage in that journey of
wanting to know
you have to engage it thoroughly
and sincerely and try your best to
remove any bias I think that's what
makes the the religion of Islam such a
phenomenon for people that with all the
islamophobia and the bigotry towards it
still the fastest growing religion in
the United States and the fastest
growing religion in the world to know
that's not all birth rate
yeah we have a lot of kids but
um many people you know you met someone
just before we started this interview
many people in fact in a post-9 11 world
solve what they saw of Islam in the
media
and they actually you know went and
checked out copies of the Quran and
started to read about the religion and
in their sincere Pursuit Of Truth ended
up embracing a religion that they
believed was the greatest source of
Destruction in the world and now it's
the greatest source of peace for them
and their own existence in their own
lives and so you have to be willing to
engage in a sincere pursuit of wanting
to know
and then be willing to engage in sincere
commitment after you know otherwise the
heart rests and so there's a process in
the Quran talks about this of making the
heart like fertile soil towards truth so
you have a sincere Pursuit but then at
some point if you come to know and then
you ignore what you come to know then
the heart rests and it becomes harder to
recognize it the second time around the
third time around and so when people
come to me and they say you know
I'm looking for something I'm looking
for I'm looking for God I'm looking for
my purpose the first thing I tell them
as I say listen
what you need to do is if you're really
looking for God in your and you believe
in God and there are often people that
say I believe in God but I don't know
where to go with this right I know that
there's something greater in Islam we
call that the fitra a natural
disposition towards the belief in the
existence of God
but where do I go from here you know
what do I do now and I say the first
thing you need to do is
you need to sincerely say oh God guide
me to the truth
call upon God sincerely say I'm calling
upon you alone and I'm asking you to
guide me to the truth show me what it is
right
and that's the heart function
then you need to actually investigate
and try to suspend bias right
investigate the world's religions
investigate the claims to Truth uh
investigate use you know rational
inquiry to the extent that the heart
becomes satisfied
and
suspend bias and you'll be surprised and
so for a lot of people
and they come to me and they say you
know this this about Islam I'm like look
I'm
if you're just going to talk to me about
what you've seen of Islam in the media
if you were serious about it you know if
you're serious about it then
uh you're not simply going to be
satisfied with
the highly edited images and distorted
facts that come towards you about this
religion right
what are you looking for right are you
are you looking for a scapegoat Islam
poses a threat to many people right are
you looking for a scapegoat are you
looking for the big bad scary foreign
enemy
or are you looking at
a religion that one-fourth of the world
adheres to and if one-fourth of us were
bad the world would not exist right so
are you looking towards this religion
that one-fourth of the world adheres to
are you going to read about the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him are you going
to read the Quran yourself are you going
to investigate for yourself uh what it
is that this faith has to offer and find
in it a great sense of of of wisdom a
great sense of beauty a great sense of
Truth
and I think that for for a lot of people
you know they they find that Islam has
such a beautiful combination of the
intellectual proofs as well as the
spiritual experiences that often combine
uh what people seek in the Western and
the Eastern religion so I had an
interesting two weeks
uh two weeks in a row
um this was August two weeks in a row I
had someone who converted to Islam
that went from being that started off as
a Methodist went from being a Methodist
to being a Buddhist to being a Muslim so
two weeks in a row I had a Methodist
turn Buddhist turned muslim okay jiren I
caught yeah I I called my my Methodist
uh friends I have a lot of Methodist
Pastors in the city that I work with and
I said what's going on here man sending
people on to this interesting journey of
Buddhism and then Islam but both of them
had a very similar story which is that
they had sought in Buddhism for example
the
you know some of the meditative
practices that are found that that
really Western religion which has been
dominated by capitalism and dominated by
by very material things and uh can be
very unfulfilling they found that in
some of the Eastern philosophies and the
meditative practices and then they came
to Islam and it combined you know their
their belief in sort of the abrahamic
way it it merged their belief in one God
and the prophets like Abraham and Moses
and Jesus peace be upon them all with a
a deep tradition of meditative practices
of consciousness of connection to God on
a regular basis and they found that to
be very fulfilling both intellectually
and spiritually and so I was like that's
interesting you know two people in two
weeks that went through that Journey so
I think Islam is is very wholesome
comprehensive when people actually
approach it with humility and uh and and
appreciate what it has to offer